the jurogan experience you know he
became uh he was it once
for uh stephen king's movie it was the
hit oh really yeah yeah
i'm afraid to watch that have you ever
seen the original the original tv one
which it was it wasn't as scary as the
yeah that's tim curry as pennywise in
the 1990s
yeah i would never watch that and it's a
good example but it's not i like him
over there
i know but that that one the the tv 1990
it is not that scary
any of them are scary my mom used to
read the book and she'd have it was like
this thick and
we would always tease her like do you
finish it yet like how what is that
about like it was just we didn't
understand it and then the movie came
out we were like yeah we're not watching
that i used to have to take uh the t
from my house to uh boston i lived in
newton and i take it to boston when i
was a teenager okay and uh what do you
mean the t the t it was like uh the
boston version of the transit system oh
oh the t jesus that's what they call it
i drink iced tea i'm literally like what
the boston tea party where are we going
sorry i thought like okay i'm sorry we
have the l so i would read something we
have the l stephen king books
and i read like basically every stephen
king book
from like
lawnmower man i like some of the short
stories all the richard bachman books i
read all of them but it was one of the
weirdest ones it's a weird yeah and it's
a giant it's like what is going on it's
a weapon for you on this going on in
your head man wow what's going on your
head you're investigating frightening
[ __ ] clown that eats kids
yeah if you look into that
would that i don't know that's scary
stephen king had so many books like that
didn't he have a lot of trauma around
him for sure well you know he grew up in
maine it's hard living up there okay and
he grew up poor you know you know he
didn't have any money like he i i've
read um
uh stephen king on writing it's an
amazing book because it tells you not
just how he writes and what he thinks
about writing but also it tells you
about like sort of the history of his
career and how difficult it was to and
when he sold i think it was carrie
it's been a while
but i think carrie was like the first
big sale that he had i think it was and
and all of a sudden he was wealthy
and and
they were trying to like look at
the numbers and they thought the numbers
were wrong on the first check they got
like what is happening oh wow yeah it's
a crazy story because you know he was
struggling he was teaching and he was
writing these books and that's how
writers do they struggle like that but
then you strike gold like he did carrie
was great with the dirty pillows so
funny did you ever he when she went to
the prom and her boobs were out why do
you have your dirty pillows out
30 pillows the [ __ ]
that's one of those things that it's
almost better if you just read it
i used to think that was a stupid idea
yeah but the there's a way that he
describes things in the book so it's
open to my mom says the same thing she's
like oh this whole scene lacks because
blah blah you know and i'm like whatever
lady
just reading it's it's like if someone
could capture it all visually that's
better right but can they capture it
visually the way that we i don't know
i think it's uh there's certain things
it's like
the way a writer writes like a guy like
stephen king like you feel
the you have access to the thoughts
that these uh characters have right you
have access to everything you have
access to not just like their actions
and how it plays out and you can't even
actually see it so you have to imagine
it which sort of stimulates your
imagination but you're also getting
access to their very thoughts right
there's weird parts of writing that like
are almost
more descriptive than seeing it because
when you're singing and hearing it it's
like it's pretty cool right you watch a
great movie with great effects and [ __ ]
and you're seeing it and hearing it it's
cool but when you're reading it there's
a weird thing that's happening where
you're you have to fill in the blank and
it stimulates your mind in a different
way
and stephen king was the master of that
yeah and it's like when if you read his
[ __ ] and then you watch his movies
you're like the movies are like he made
some goddamn amazing movies no doubt
about it
like carrie freaked me out
to me carrie was detailed enough but if
i was reading the book i probably would
never sleep i think that was a movie
that was a book rather he doesn't
remember writing
oh pretty sure i'm pretty sure was he on
adderall no he was sorry he was coked up
and he was doing he was drinking like
crazy i think that was one of the ones i
think was carrie
and maybe uh christine
oh christine maybe it was cujo this is
maybe the c word it's a c word i think
it was cujo
i think i got stuck on a c there's so
many good books man but uh i think it
was cujo i think cujo he wrote when he
was so high and so [ __ ] up he
literally just doesn't remember writing
it
it is funny just to get stuck on a
letter i don't know why listen i'm not a
[ __ ] i'm not the person what can we
call this what can we call the dog here
it is stephen king discusses cujo in on
writing referring to as a novel he
barely remembers writing at all that's
it there it is king wrote the book
during the height of a struggle with
alcohol addiction or
killing it
right
to say he likes the book the movie he
wishes he could remember enjoying the
good parts as he put them on the page
wow it's a great [ __ ] book though
amazing reading that book
i think would be insanely crazy because
like even watching the movie you get
frustrated you're like do this do that
you know like movies not good no yeah
it's not good it's not the best but
you're like why didn't they just do this
or why didn't they use it but maybe in
the book
it it had more
i was going to say is the movie's not
good at expressing
the layers and layers of fear and
recognition that this dog who was your
lovable pet is now going to kill you
yeah
it's it's too hard to do
it's too hard to do in a movie it's
it's too hard to do it takes too much
time if you're reading a book it's like
what's what's the average amount of time
it takes to read
a book like cujo like how many pages is
cujo i'm going to say let me guess
396 pages no 309 really oh
damn
oh maybe i'm i was off by 100. it's
terrible
i knew i was getting to the three of
them
to be honest
it wasn't i was thinking higher i was
thinking like five because i don't know
why but i was thinking it was way higher
well then you get into like the stand
right because i'm thinking of all those
books on my mom's show like they're the
stand is really long how long is the
stand
have you ever read that i've never
finished that i'm not a big problem i've
read quite a bit of it and then i bail
yeah i don't 120 325
that's what i'm saying that's in the
uncut version so 300 more pages holy
[ __ ] you know what got me into reading
though like that kind of story that
style of book is the hobbit
my mom or my stepdad or can't remember
which one gave me the hobbit in like the
70s okay and i read that i was like whoa
what a crazy book and then there was a
movie there was like a hobbit animated
movie that came out in like the late 70s
it's like whack
old school animation we could tell
people were drawing it you can see their
hands you're like why are we that's what
got me into those kind of books though
but i remember going through puberty my
mom gave me little women and i was like
is there a movie
i can't
i think i did read little women there
was like a three box set or something
well when i was a kid when i was stuck
on the train all the time headed into
the city there's no
phones you didn't have a phone so you
had to read a book
like there was no other options so it
was like for me it was always like
either stephen king [ __ ] or
you know whatever whatever i could find
that was interesting
watch the entire episode for free only
on spotify